alors alex est né à alès oui vous rêviez
temps petit de devenir gardienne de
chèvres
c'est vraiment comment vous savez ça oui
et puis ensuite formation de théâtre
classique au conservatoire de nîmes et
en 92 vous débarquez à paris pour des
auditions vous commencé le théâtre les
téléfilms vous êtes évincée du casting
d'un gars une fille départ à cause d'un
mauvais partenaire vous redemander une
chance et cette fois c'est jean mais il
a dit à la productrice c'est une nana
qui pourrait me faire donc ça c'était
décision
ouais il a dit isabelle camus il faut la
prendre parce qu elle vraiment j'ai
envie de me la taper
ça c'est le chinon
genre mais à rueil malmaison
après le bac et le service militaire
deux ans serrurier dans le bâtiment oui
ça apprend la vie ça non ouais ouais
j'ai cgt comique en bâtiment le mic en
matinée
et le soin one man show dans des cafés
théâtres et puis membre de la bande du
carré blanc
est là un jour
jean bouchard garin déniché par stéphane
calvet le directeur artistique de
l'émission vous faites graines de stars
way et vous gagner trois fois de suite
ouais c'est vrai j'ai le record
chaque fois vous gérez vous les plus
jamais ça et vous vous y retournez quand
même ouais c'est vrai c'est super
souvenir quoi c'était c'était fabuleux
super pétoche mais bien moins content
mais c'est là on s'est rencontré
d'ailleurs voilà et on va voir avec quoi
vous avez gagné
salut
salut saffar sa forte ça farte bombe
welcome sur la plage de lacanau beach
je me présente je m'appelle brisse
julien de nice de nice
tu sais comment elle m'appelle les
familles six mois le sniper
suis harcelé la journée je me casse la
baraque à frites obligé de surf et la
nuit à la bougie
mais la nuit c'est les sirènes qui me
gonfle non attendez attendez je veux
dire c'est dur d'être un canon je le
souhaite à personne
en plus moi le style blondasse plastique
féline et je vais te dire ça me laisse
rêveur f
d'ailleurs si une pitchouns dans le
groupe un peu raboteuse qui aiment le
gall ac
rendez vous ce soir en camping des
vaniteux emplacement de l demande brice
rois de la glisse
et alors là vous décidez avec avec vos
copains de l'époque la bande du carré
blanc de créer une troupe de faire les
nous c nous et qui fait ça
c
sagard et
chez nous
beaucoup d'émissions de télévision des
parodies sur france2 d'ailleurs souvent
est alors en 99 isabelle camus la
productrice et le pense d'abord à josé
garcia pour un gars une fille puis voilà
il était pris par le cinéma et c'est lui
qui a suggéré votre nom oh ouais c'est
ça c'est vrai mais c'est bien sûr c'est
vrai ah oui j'y allais à reculons départ
ouais parce que j'étais en train de
repeindre la chambre de mon fils et puis
moi les castings c'est pas elles sont
pas super bien quoi donc elle m'a
appelée puis elle m'a montré les les
vidéos des canadiens donc et puis ça m'a
plu vous avez vu cinq filles et puis la
6e c'était c'était alex wall a ouai ouai
puis c'est passé tout de suite enfants
ont envie d'élire mêmes débits un grande
complicité tout de suite ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'est ce qu'il dit en
parlant de vous ai dit c'est mon pote
avec des seins
en même temps c'est c'est sympa et pas
ça
oui justement alors j'ai des problèmes
avec vos conjoints respectifs
il paraît qu'ils vous embrasse plus
souvent que votre jules
c'est pas vrai bon c'est thierry
ardisson
mais à peu près équivalente
origines d'organiser un dîner 1 c'est
vrai oui on s'est rencontré deux coups
pour être sûr qu'il n'y avait pas fait
d'autre qu'à quatre mois
c'était lui ou après après quoi
on t'a rejoint
en émission
et puis